I don't know dad I mean it looks like a
bunch of little kids live here it's nice
it's festive it's like your own sad
little Christmas parade
I heard you got out of finance it's a
system of monstrous greed and for what
more toys bigger houses so you have some
big plans you know
charity work they don't know yeah which
one disease diseases you know and they
can't cancer spectrum so are you
separated no I'm divorced do you have
kids yeah yeah I do have you even looked
for a job yet yeah I got one oh you did
oh yeah I did
delivering booze do you live here I
didn't think this was your style I mean
what's your style delivering liquor
looks that way I just kind of hang Grant
Road a little bit like the guy you see
sitting across from you right now oh
lucky me full let's wake up back let's
just the same what happened to you like
quit your fancy job something had to
change
ain't the same mistake Smith you can't
just come in here you're drunk
what I'm just getting some things man
everyone needs to relax a weird flavor
are you kidding me nope tastes like
flowers what is wrong with you Anders
you are the one who wanted out so get
out you know when I saw you at the
window just now I thought you were him I
have some questions for you Rustin did
did not do anything
I swear to God I did not tell anyone how
could you not call us [ __ ] you my like
this
you brought me Mirotic stolen library
book yeah I'm sorry you have such a
disappointing dad okay
[Music]
I accept this vision my life was like a
web the more webs could have coming from
you than the more important you were but
if you vanish then the people that were
in your life they learn to rely on
someone else and then the web just
remakes itself and moves on without you
[Music]
you
[Music]